Progreso tecnológico para unos y peligro
potencial para otros la Inteligencia
artificial evoluciona a un ritmo
vertiginoso pero la normativa del sector
sigue siendo en gran medida un terreno
inexplorado algo que la Unión Europea y
Estados Unidos intentan cambiar ahora
con un nuevo código de conducta
voluntario
avanzaremos en un borrador de código de
conducta sobre Inteligencia artificial
en las próximas semanas teniendo en
cuenta los comentarios de la industria
los comentarios de los independientes
Europa ha estado avanzando en un marco
jurídico vinculante sobre el sector de
la Inteligencia artificial que
prohibiría la vigilancia biométrica y
garantizaría el control humano de las
tecnologías aunque las normas no
entrarían en vigor sino hasta antes de
2025 Estados Unidos sede de grandes
empresas que desarrollan esta tecnología
como meta Google Amazon y opening ha
acordado un código de conducta con
directrices jurídicamente No vinculantes
creo que compartimos la convicción de
que el consejo comercio y tecnología
entre la Unión Europea y Estados Unidos
tiene un importante papel que desempeñar
para ayudarnos a establecer códigos de
conducta que estén abiertos a todos los
países que lo deseen Estados Unidos y la
Unión Europea esperan conseguir aliados
en el proyecto entre ellos Reino Unido
Canadá e India China también ha debatido
la normativa pero las potencias
occidentales temen que la creciente
destreza de Beijing en este campo y su
voluntad de exportar a otros países
autoritarios pueda establecer normas
mundiales